[Applause]
but here is a calming news this week we
found out why Queen Elizabeth died
really they put this out old age really
oh wow
I thought you might have fell out a
window in Moscow
oh that situation is not getting any
better with Russia Russia annexed 15 of
Ukraine this week did you see that just
essay report in a bit this is the
largest annexation Russia has done since
the uh well I got to go back to the
Republican party in 2016.
foreign
things now Mega people
we gotta make that distinction because
like the did you see Ginny Thomas is in
the news this week she is the wife of
the Supreme Court Justice Clarence
Thomas wow she appeared before the giant
racist committee and told them she still
thinks that Trump won
in 2020 the election was stolen wow
there are conspiracy theorists and then
there's this lady I mean
she's she also said that she thinks for
the last 35 years uh there's been a
black man lurking around her home
[Applause]
the Republicans of course lost their
[ __ ] this week because Biden made a
gaffe the kind he's made for 50 years
that matters not about anything but
there's a congresswoman named Jackie
wolorski who unfortunately died a couple
of months ago this 535 members of
Congress okay so Biden is speaking and
he calls for Jackie Jackie where are you
well dead yes okay I'm not saying it was
a great moment but
okay again 535 members he forgot that
she was dead the last guy forgot we were
a democracy
a little perspective
[Music]
[Applause]
Trump was once was giving a speech and
he about the American Revolution
came up in this speech and he said our
army manned the air
[Laughter]
rammed the ramparts and took over the
airports in 1776.
and he was reading it
I swear to God
so you know
I'm just gonna say one day the phone is
going to ring and Marjorie Taylor green
is going to answer the gun
and then we could talk about whose brain
works all the time and who's doesn't
okay oh Marjorie Taylor green back on
the market I don't know if you heard
uh but she's getting divorced yes very
sad she caught him with another imbecile